[Music]
right to the point here we will explain
and classify the seven enemy super
species of Godzilla in the monsterverse
these Titans here unlike others that
recognize titanis Gojira as the alpha
instead challenged his dominance which
has led to battles and Wars against him
and his species throughout the natural
history of the world we will classify
them according to their specific niches
and habits and their relation to him and
his species which makes all the
difference as you will see here let's
get to
it the first one an ancient pest species
much like how Locust can strip off the
farmlands of food crops and starve
humans to death by that action so thus
the shinamura species do the same with
Godzilla's radiation and food sources
the shinamura is an ancient peran perod
Colony species made up of billions of
small starfish-like cells that are each
capable of generating a new Titan if
given the circumstances and conditions
this creature is hated by Godzilla due
to the fact that it also feeds on the
same radiation sources and also Titan
carcasses which might have given an
ancient Gojira species food and
nourishment as well this was seen in
Godzilla Awakening where flashbacks to
the peran period hint at the intense
hatred Godzilla has for this species in
the ancient p and this carried over by
instinct to the current king of the
monsters and by the way if shinamura was
to ever feed on enough energy or
radiation it could grow to overpower the
Gman and become the top predator of the
earth number two the hollow Earth rival
species of course there would have been
quite a few super species or Titans that
have challenged Godzilla for dominance
over the course of millions of years and
as we can see with the genitor Titan or
sub Tian but as far as we know there is
only one in the the hollow Earth that is
the species that can rival uh titanus
Gojira and that is the titanis Kong
species this rivalry led to an allout
war between the goira species and its
allies versus the Kongs and their allies
as well and as we all know and saw in
GVK the kingdom of the Kongs was
decimated and this drived the remnants
to Skull Island along with the Eevee
people making it their second home this
is also evident in the great hatred
Godzilla has for Kong and vice versa and
now in gxk the new Empire another one of
the ks is set to appear another one that
was defeated by Godzilla in the past and
his name is scar
King number three the enemies which are
the life cycle parasitic species so
these Titans right here are the most
hated species by Godzilla they are the
mutos and most specifically the muto
Prime we have seen in the comics
Godzilla Aftershock that Muto Prime has
in the past killed K not one but two
goera specimens one is dayone found in
the Philippines and another bigger one
was discovered in Siberia the muto life
cycle is a plague on the earth it
requires a living goera for its pores to
be injected in and then thrive in the
radiation rich blood inside the body and
then when it's all gone it will Break
Free Break Out and mature into adult
specimens over time that will lay eggs
to give rise to even more male and
female mutos that will feed on
everything living hence causing mass
extinctions in the past they will then
feed on and kill each other until the
last surviving member evolves into the
muto Prime and hence restarting the
cycle for Godzilla this is a fate worse
than death so that's why he hunted and
killed both mutos in San Francisco and
also killed the muto Prime in
Montana number four an invasive alien
species in the mon verse this is King
gidora or otherwise originally called
there as Monster Zero when he was
discovered Frozen in the Antarctic ice
sheet and it is stated that it was an
extraterrestrial life form an alien
returning to its original roots in the
showah period gidora stands out as the
most malevolent and hostile Titan
encountered thus far Monster Zero is an
alien invasive species that has no place
in the earth's ecosystem it has a
bioelectric biology which is way
different from any animal or Titan found
here in the monsterverse its Basic
Instinct or primary objective is to
seize command of Earth's Titans from
Godzilla the rightful Alpha species and
ruler and protector Godzilla the king of
the monsters and the rightful Alpha
species Harbors animosity towards gdor
due to the L's invasive and destructive
actions Godzilla's hatred stems from the
sense of responsibility to maintain
balance and protect the Earth from the
catastrophic consequences of gor's Reign
which would have led to a every living
thing
dying number five a new enemy a superior
progenitor species so this is all still
rumors and internet gossip but titanis
shimu is now thought of as the original
Titan on Earth from where did he come
from or how he evolved that is up for
anyone to say but as far as we know he
is stated to be the progenitor of the
Titans he has an icy breath power and is
somehow under the mind control of
scaring who holds a whip a mine whip
let's say and therefore they both will
combine their powers and battle against
a team up of Godzilla and gong but as to
the status or the relationship between
him shimu and Godzilla we can only refer
to the Call of Duty war zone Easter egg
that painting that cave painting that
was seen of a Godzilla fighting titanis
shimu and we can infer that if this was
in the past that it happened an Ancient
Godzilla would have lost a match to the
to the superior progenitor species
called titanis shimu the sixth enemy an
oceanic rival species so this one is
Tiamat she is a Titanic Serpentine
creature with scales that are serrated
and a skull that looks draconic with
yellow eyes and four barbles extending
from the phas which looks like mustache
Tiamat is a very territorial super
species a Titan and will fight other
Titans for dominance her aggressive and
destructive Nature has led to Monarch
classifying Tiamat as a destroyer
centuries or thousands of years ago in
the past unsure of the exact timeline
Tiamat fought and killed a titanis Kong
when she invaded his layer the same Kong
that was said to have defeated Godzilla
in combat in the past and was turned as
the Rival so Tiamat in doing so in fact
became an alpha Titan 2o defeating a
Titan that defeated Godzilla and almost
won against Godzilla underwater in that
fight in Dominion and it wasn't until
the fight was dragged on land that she
lost in a way she is an oceanic rival
species and lastly an artificial
invasive Mecca species in the same way
that mon zero or gidora has no place in
the planet's ecosystem the same goes for
Mecha Godzilla which is for all intents
and purposes and gidora reincarnated
although with the skeletal and body
framework created by Apex cybernetics to
mimic and eventually become Superior to
Godzilla himself self the mecca was
eventually overtaken by the
consciousness of gidora which had two of
its skulls and brains part of the
project and the robotic body so when
Garo realized that the mecca was
completely independent in energy Supply
with the synthesization of the power
source from the hollow Earth it gained
full control of the Mecca and began its
killing Rampage once more if left
unchecked the same thing would have
happened all life on Earth would be
extinguished and that is why Godzilla
and Kong had to team up to take it down
it was the Ultimate
Enemy so those are the seven enemy
species of Godzilla in the monsterverse
if you like this video then watch this
one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie Monsters
contents and creatures then check out
our Channel as we might have things that
you haven't seen before or thought about
like subscribe and we'll see you on the
next video take care fam